hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll
one of the interesting things about
science is that
people within science the working
scientists can get really quite
emotional and tied up
in their favorite ideas even if we don't
yet know which idea is right
even if we're convinced that eventually
the experiments are going to have the
last word and they're going to tell us
which ideas are right
along the way we get very attached we
care
about one idea being right or the other
one which is very different than
the stereotype of the cold and
analytical science type
part of that is of course that the
interesting part of being a theoretical
physicist
the kind of scientist that i am is
proposing
new ideas for what the fundamental laws
of nature might be
a lot of theoretical physics is taking
the known laws of nature
and working out what their consequences
are so how do stars form how do you make
a high temperature superconductor how
does dna
split and things like that but another
part of it is proposing entirely better
newer novel ideas for what the
fundamental laws
are supposed to be and when it comes to
that how in the world
are we supposed to know how to best
invent
new laws or if someone proposes some new
laws how in the world are we supposed to
say
yeah that seems plausible to me or no no
that's completely crazy
this is a judgment call this is
something people who are
completely working in good faith will
have different ideas about
so today's guest is lis mullen probably
needs no introduction
very well known to any of you who are
interested in theoretical physics
lee is one of the pioneers of loop
quantum gravity
he is one of the founding members of the
perimeter institute for theoretical
physics
in waterloo canada and one of the
interesting things about lee is that
not only is he working in quantum
gravity and related fields
but he thinks very carefully about how
to be
a theoretical physicist and the other
interesting thing is
his answer to that question is different
than most theoretical physicists
answer is to be honest a lot of
theoretical physicists you know have
some feelings about what works and what
doesn't
but they don't reflect on it that much
they just march forward i think this
idea is good let's look at that
whereas lee really thinks about the
philosophical
underpinnings of what he's doing tries
to build a coherent story based on
principles that one should follow to say
here's what should come next
and the reason i like it is because i
love that way of working
and yet lee and i come to completely
different answers about almost all of
the interesting issues
in theoretical physics so i think that
this is a very interesting conversation
to listen to both because of the
substance of the theoretical physics
ideas we talk about
and also for the stylistic questions of
how physicists or
scholars and intellectuals more broadly
should proceed in developing new ideas
anyway let me remind you that uh we love
it here at mindscape when you do things
like
leave reviews of the podcast on itunes
etc or
you can support mindscape by going to
patreon go to patreon.com
sean m carroll and uh you can become a
patron that lets you ask ask me anything
questions get ad-free
episodes of the podcast and generally
feel good about yourself with all that
let's go
lee small and welcome to the mindscape
podcast thank you very much
so it's great to have you on you've
clearly you know written a lot about
different topics in physics many of
which overlap with things that i've
written about so
before we get to specifics of your
recent work i thought
for the audience members out there for
the one or two who are not familiar with
your work it would be fun just to go
through and
give some of the positions some of the
basic ideas that you've been thinking
about over the years so why don't we
start with the most obvious one which is
quantum gravity
right you spend a lot of your physics
career thinking about quantum gravity
uh i bet that most listeners of
mindscape understand
that quantum gravity is a thing that we
need to understand but let's
let's put those people aside and for the
ones who are not familiar with the
problem how do you
even say what the issue is when it comes
to reconciling quantum mechanics and
gravity
so the way that i say is that
einstein started this revolution in
physics
in 1905 and there were two parts to the
revolution
quantum theory which einstein really got
started on
got it started on and the revolution in
thinking about space and time and
gravity and cosmology which came with
general relativity
and my sense is that we're still in the
midst of this revolution
and they're particularly
challenging are two aspects of it well
i'll say three aspects
which i think are all connected one is
to make sense of quantum mechanics and
of course you and i both have a lot to
say about that
but another one is to
get a description of
the gravitational field and space-time
in the same terms as the other physical
fields
and i say this because um i tend to
agree with einstein
that bringing together gravity and the
other forces
will will change our description of the
other forces as much as
gravity so whether we'll relativize the
quantum or quantize
relativity um certainly i've
thought about both of those things and
then there's another set of problems
which i think
are deeply related to those which is how
the universe chose the laws
that it seems to have chosen not just
what are the laws
but why were they why are they the laws
how were they chosen
right you of course famously have been
working or
was a were a pioneer of loop quantum
gravity in particular what is your
what is your current state of thinking
about how loop quantum gravity is doing
was it a step in the right direction uh
is it still uh
on the table or do we not know yet good
so um can i tell a little bit about that
story the way that
i tell it which is i think different
from how some other people tell it
so i wanted to do quantum gravity coming
into undergraduate school and graduate
school
but i went to graduate school at harvard
during a period when the standard model
had just a few years ago
been invented and it was full of all
that wonderful physics
and i particularly got captivated by the
physics
of ken wilson and sasha palikov sasha
migdal
and a number of other people who were
interested in the idea
analogous to the quantization of
magnetic flux in the superconductor
that you could have something like the
electromagnetic field namely these gauge
fields
where the electric field flux got
quantized
and that would lead to a sort of picture
of
the electric flux being carried along
strings
that had quartz at the ends of them and
that heuristic picture
as it developed with qcd had a powerful
influence on me and i thought and i
think i was just
in the right place at the right time
that
how natural it would be to apply those
same methods and same ideas
to the gravitational field so that's
what i started off doing my first paper
was the version of lattice quantum
gravity
in which the loops of quantized electric
flux
on the lattice were the main actors now
we would call it a symphony
so sorry just to just to be clear for
the people who are not uh this is this
is great stuff because i'm very
interested in what you're saying but it
might not be familiar to everyone so
there is this technique for
understanding the strong interactions
like you said
the the gluon fields that hold quarks
together
um that thinks not just about the field
at every point in space
but what happens when you go around a
loop so that's an existing
thing in the study of the strong
interactions and you're saying so
your inspiration was to do that for
gravity
right and it was pure theft
and so what was needed
was a good formulation of general
relativity
that made the analog of the gauge fields
that tell you
how to move things around what we call
parallel transport
around space that that
those are the variables in young mills
theory and we needed a formulation of
general relativity
that focused on the same kinds of
variables
in general relativity and abitab
those in late 1985
and then it was just like snapping
little toys together so to speak
and that so so why i want to emphasize
that
is for me it's it's an idea and it's a
powerful idea
and at the kinematical level it gave us
very
interesting insight and results um
string theory which had been developing
and had started to get interested in
quantum gravity in a big way
two or three years before that um it was
not different
in my mind it was also the development
of these quantized
loops of electric flux you know the so
let me just put in to say the very first
person
that i interviewed uh not the first
episode i published but the first person
i interviewed for the mindscape podcast
was carlo revelli
and at the end i said so do you think
that there is some hope for you know
string theory and loop quantum gravity
to come together and
and merge in some common understanding
and he said no
[Laughter]
so you might want to put your opinion
about that also well carlo and i
are dear dear old friends and we
disagree about many many things
but and i don't know how probably it
will be but just
my mindset and the way that i looked at
the problem of quantum gravity
was those were different versions of the
same idea
and i certainly tried to bring them
closer
and carla would be right to say without
much success
but the thing that then happened
sort of sociologically in which there
were these two
communities of people who didn't
understand
each other i was very much against
from at both sides so um
so so i don't see them really
certainly they have different they've
taken away different shapes
but i think the following things i would
i would defend saying it the following
ways
each of them and a number of other
approaches as well
have some brilliant successes and that
makes us
really interested each of them has
roadblocks which have been there for at
least 20
years and longer and i
think it's ridiculous that we continue
and in fact we're not continuing very
much if you look at
what the new people coming into the
field are doing
um there's very little pure
i would say luke nobody is doing what we
were doing 25 years ago thankfully
for just a handful the last time i saw a
paper or heard a talk in which somebody
actually calculated a string amplitude
it's a long time ago and yeah some of
what the
really interesting young people are
doing are is hard to classify
it's some of this and some of this and
they walk between the communities and
they don't notice
that there are barriers and i mean
somebody like
like sabrina gonzalez patricia and um
laura just said there's a lot so
that's what i'm hopeful for i think
that's right you know
i've had a few string theorists on the
show also and i always like to ask them
do you call yourself a string theorist
and they always say no
[Laughter]
all the modern strength theories even
lenny suskin who is you know
modern in the sense of uh pushing the
field forward but not modern in the
sense of when he appeared on the scene
uh you know doesn't think of himself
under that label because like you say
the boundaries are falling between them
but let me just
go in in one further step in that
direction because
back in the day at least one of the
arguments uh
between people who were on the loo
quantum gravity side and people on the
string
theory side was whether or not you could
really make
progress by thinking about gravity in
and of itself apart from the other
forces of nature and
one of the string theory arguments was
you can't uh i mean they only made up
that argument because they seem to have
a way of doing them all at the same time
what is your feeling about that now i
mean does it make sense to think about
quantum gravity as a field apart from
everything else or do you have to just
dive right in and get a theory of
everything
i think it happens to make sense to
think about
quantizing the gravitational field
without matter
but um it's much better to try to
include matter
i i i matt the world is full of matter
when you include mata there are some
questions
right away that are really compelling to
think about
one of them is that mata comes
cairo which maybe not everybody knows
the words but
looking at the particles in the standard
model especially the neutrinos
in a mirror they're not the same there's
not a symmetry under looking at nature
in the mirror
right and um that seems
that seems tempting to think of that as
fundamental
and there are some reasons we can talk
about that and then you but then we're
supposed to connect that up with gravity
which at the classical level is
completely left right symmetric
and that seems odd and one of the
attractions
of the original ashtakar way of thinking
about
the gravitational field was that it is
also
chiral and there's this sort of hidden
chirality
which is if you look at it in the right
twisted way
it looks simpler and that's true of a
number of other developments
in space-time theory like twister theory
project penrose's
invention so um i
i certainly think this matter in the
world
and i'm i'm very interested in the
question
of why this matter right it's not just
that they're gaze theories
but why sd3 class sc2 plus u1
good and then the other thing i wanted
to get on the table was um
one outgrowth of string theory in the
late 90s was
the idea of the multiverse and the
anthropic principle i mean it was a
pre-existing idea but it became very
very popular with the string theory
landscape of different possibilities you
were a critic
of the way that that was approached in
the string theory community with the
anthropic principle
um but you have your own ideas about
cosmological natural selection and so
forth which to some outsiders seem
similar even though you were criticizing
the string theory version so
can you tell the people who don't know
anything about these ongoing debates
where you come down there
well again let's let me start um
if it's not too self-referential please
with how i started
on this so um andy straminger
who was a friend called me one day at
least this is the way i remember
it and there was so string theory
at first in 1984 there were five
versions of string theory in 10
dimensions
and then they were if you found out you
could
curl up the extra six dimensions and
with some beautiful elegant complex
geometry
you could classify some of the different
ways to curl them up
and they were supposed to be several
hundred thousand variants according to
yao who we all admired but nobody
understood the argument
and um and there was a sort of idea that
we would look and pick among the 100 000
or so
and find the one that must be that looks
just like the standard model everyone
and andy had realized that there were
uncountably many more that was just the
tip of the iceberg and he wrote a paper
about that
and when he called me he was very
despairing about that he says
we'll never get any phenomenology out of
this because how are we going to search
this vast huge space to find the
standard mono
and so at that point just
they're these serendipitous things um i
was reading a lot of theoretical
evolutionary theory
just for fun and you know you
you must know the the attractiveness of
reading
stephen j gould did his prime or lynn
margulis
there was wonderful stuff so i kind of
had it on the brain
and i started to think could you attack
the biology solves that problem is a
huge landscape
and the word comes from there comes from
the population biology
there's a huge landscape that population
biologists talk about
and they have a basically a mechanism to
search to think about it like a
mathematical
geneticist they have a mechanism to
search this landscape
and find optimal creatures find
creatures that
whose fitness is optimized so i started
thinking
along those lines and just ask can i
invent a scenario
where there would be something that
would be extremized
and one of the things i thought about
which was the thing that i published
under cosmological natural selection was
that what the universe wanted to do was
reproduce itself
and reproduced itself through black
holes that led to baby universes
that was an old idea and that was
due to johnny wheeler and other people
of that time
also due to johnny was the idea
that the conscience of nature changed
when you went through that transition to
new baby human earth
he called it reprocessing the universe
and he imagined
that everything was just changing
randomly
and all i had to add was a constraint
that said no
on the average for dimension of the list
constants the change per generation is
small
and then you have a search procedure
that will discover
those regions of parameter space that
leads to universes that have a lot of
black holes
so that was the idea and i
then had to learn a lot of astronomy and
astrophysics which was great
and um and put together some sense of
whether that was possible
so so i published that idea
it makes a very small number of
predictions and i
from following those predictions um
i don't think it's likely right
it's and i deeply dislike the fact that
to work it depends on multiple
versions of the universe although
they're rather differently organized
than in the eternal
the internal inflation picture i'm still
certainly
well not me but that idea is guilty of
propagating many universes to explain
our own
and i deeply dislike that but i
i will point to the fact that it makes
predictions
as a kind of proof of concept okay so
both the string theory landscape and
your version of cosmological natural
selection
involve many many different universes
with different features
but you're saying that if i understood
correctly because your universes change
slowly uh and you can you can look for
the solution that maximizes their
reproductive
fitness and that makes more predictions
than the string theory
landscape does yes but it's zero versus
twos
okay i mean i think that
go ahead any of them would make
predictions like the cosmological
constant allows for the existence of
life right
yeah um yes but
um what what to be a real prediction
it has to be a feature of the universe
that's decoupled from or orthogonal to
whether it is life or not okay no one of
those predictions is about the
value of the strange quark mass and the
relation that it has to the upper limit
of masses of neutron stars
and as far as i can tell that's not
coupled to whether we exist or not
okay that makes sense with world-class
instructors
curated music and endless fitness
variety peloton has created an unmatched
fitness experience to keep you motivated
workout after workout i like peloton
because it's flexible about what kind of
workout you're going to get in the
moment sometimes you want a relaxing
bike ride
other times you want a challenging
strength and cardio workout
with epic artist collaborations and
instructor curated playlists
peloton's music experience is unlike any
other
whether you're in the mood for hip-hop
or pop or country the peloton bike has
the right music to keep you entertained
and motivated all year long
the peloton all-access membership is
more like a family plan for no
additional cost
bring home the peloton experience for
your whole family with access to their
entire class library
encouragement from expert instructors
and the convenience of working out in
your home on your time
so get started on your peloton journey
go to onepeleton.com to learn more
that's
o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t-o-n.com
um and then the final thing to get on
the ground because it's very related to
this
multiverse question is the many worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics one
of my favorite ideas
and uh you've written a book recently
einstein's unfinished revolution where
you talk a lot about quantum mechanics
and you make it clear
that uh many worlds is not on your list
of viable alternatives
so maybe you want to share with the
audience why you think that's the case
let me practice that um and i'm not just
saying that because this is your program
um if you look at that book
you'll see that the many worlds of the
everett approach has two chapters
and has the longest chapters in the book
so
i take you guys seriously good
and i spent a lot in fact that was in
agony for me
because i i do
not believe for various reasons that i i
hope we'll talk about
that that's the way nature is organized
but
i think that there's been
the there's a world of things that have
happened since the original
average bryce dewitt kind of sense of it
and there's a number of people in oxford
who
you know who they are and yourself and
your collaborators and a number of other
people
who have worked really seriously to make
sense of that interpretation or the
original claims of that interpretation
and it was really challenging for me to
try to understand
what was going on because it's pretty
subtle at least for a dumb guy or
whatever like me
it was pretty subtle and i wanted to
present this to
you know when we're writing these books
some of it is to promote our own
ideas but some of it is the
responsibility
of just get presenting it to the public
so they can choose so they can get it
right sure
and um so we can talk about the ins and
outs of that
um but that's that's my practice
yep and with that preface on the table
why don't you
like many worlds having done all this
agonizing work
what level of personal explanation would
you like so let me start with
um it cuts off my hopes so my hopes
are and have always been um
that quantum mechanics was incomplete
and there was a physical theory that is
physical discoveries to be made
which would be enlightening about the
nature of space
and time and that's always been
the goal of the work that i've been
trying to do in quantum foundations
so the minimal thing to say is that if
you're right
then i have nothing there's nothing to
do in the direction
i've been working and i don't it's not
that i
feel like i have a great state but
i i it's taken a lot of time and effort
and i
i i still believe that that's a likely
or
to me it's a very possible direction for
science
good so let me actually let me just sort
of reiterate that in my own words so you
can tell me if i'm understanding
correctly
um one of the things about everett the
many world's interpretation is
it says that we basically do understand
quantum mechanics we understand
what the sort of space of quantum states
is how it evolves
there's a tremendous amount of work to
be done to quote-unquote interpret it
to figure out how that simple underlying
description
matches on to the world that we see but
the basic physics is somehow
there and what you're saying is that you
have either a hope or a desire or an
intuition or a thought
that we don't understand the basic
quantum dynamics and that
trying different versions of that might
help us understand other problems in
physics so you don't want to shut that
off in the way that everett might see
appear to do yes um at least i want to
go ahead in my little corner
and and develop that because
i think that that's tied
to the question about how the universe
chose its laws
i think it's tied to quantum gravity and
especially what ties into quantum
gravity
is the hypothesis that space is not
fundamental and that space is therefore
emergent
out of something more fundamental
and that non-local that
something being emergent the property
that we call locality the things talk
with other things nearby them
would be disordered say the condensed
matter physicists say
to have non-locality appearing
in the universe and that non-locality
could play a role
in the non-locality that we discover in
quantum phenomena
and that's that's an interesting
question so
that is part of the picture i have the
map i have in my head
of where of where i'm going well that
makes sense and in fact it's a perfect
segue because i did want to get into now
uh the specific ideas so thank you for
indulging me with that little
uh set of background questions but i i
thought it might be fun to start
in your because in your book you you
you're very interested in philosophy
as well as science and you've taken
seriously a lot of uh philosophers not
just the most modern philosophers
doing quantum foundations or whatever
but the history of philosophy and a lot
of thoughts from that
and one of the perspectives you put
forward
is that you would like whatever our
physical theory that we developed to be
to come from some well-articulated
principles
and you say that einstein did this you
know with relativity for example
we should at least give it a try and
then you you list in your in your book
in einstein's unfinished revolution you
have five principles
that you want a theory to follow now i
don't want to put you on the spot do you
want to tell us what the five principles
are do you want me to
mention them and then you can comment
well let's
i have different versions of this so
let's see if it's the same i'll start
off and
we'll see if it's the same time good um
all the lists that i've written down
start with the idea of relationalism
as the first one that is the principles
that
leidness laid out in his writings about
how to make a background independent
theory of
quantum gravity and quantum cosmology
which is what liveness was doing
in my opinion so by the way in your book
that's principle number two
that's not principle number one
number one is probably realism then nope
it's background independence
i messed up i'm sorry independence
is a clear consequence of lying this is
princess but anyway
exactly but i mean i actually i just i'm
only drawing this out because
as a fellow book writer and you know we
know better than the people who are
reading the books that
they're they evolve in time right like
the book that you actually read is just
a snapshot of what it was when you when
you had to hand it in
but if you were given more time you'd
probably keep tweaking it along the way
oh of course of course so what is
relationalism then you know what
what does that mean in in down-to-earth
terms in down-to-earth terms that means
that
there's no such thing as absolutely
where you are in space
is where you are relative to some
landmarks which you have to pick out
there is the same thing is true of time
there's no
absolute time which goes on whether
there's any change or emotion in the
world
you the principles of
liveness say you have to describe
time in terms of change and
use some actual we would say a physical
clock
we don't believe the way newton believed
that there's some
view of god which gives absolutely where
things are
and when things are that they all it all
comes down to relationships
one of the ways that liveness put it
is is the part is the principle is
called
i'll say it in other words and it'll
come from okay
the principle is that there can be no
two events in the world
that are identical described by the
relational properties so or no two
objects
so if you have an event and you look
around you
and you see a certain view around you
you have another event which sees
exactly the same view around
it then they must be the same event this
is the identity of indiscernibles
this is the identity understandable
thank you the principal identity
and i find this a very useful principle
for constructing
theories and i get the impression from
reading those those principles in
particular but the whole thing
that part of your intuition is that we
make progress by stripping away
given elements right like the the less
the ultimate theory of physics
says well this is just fixed once and
for all and we can't change it
the happier you are and so we went from
there from newton
newtonian absolute space to einstein and
now quantum mechanics and it's a
it's a series of stripping away of
absolutes yes
and i think more specifically
um the way that i'd like to say this is
that we live inside this universe
this one universe for purposes of
discussion give me that for a moment
there's one universe
and we're trying to understand its
properties now what we do
mostly is this is is we look at a small
part of it
a ball rolling down an incline playing a
rocket shooting off a solar system
a phone whatever and we treat the
physics of that
in isolation that is we pretend it's
isolated from other things in the
universe
but not completely because we have to
we'd like to use
big solid stable things in the rest of
the universe
like the whole solar system itself to
give
meaning to measurements that we make on
these small things
so the way that we actually
test the theory implicitly assumes that
we're discussing a small part of the
universe which is only
weakly interacting with the rest of the
universe so
that's fine and that works very well but
it if you're cognizant of that
and like you and i both want to to
make a theory of the whole universe and
understand
the universe as a something that stands
alone and is in some sense or
a whole closed system then you've got to
find a different starting point
and that's one of the lessons of
thinking through these
ideas trying to get good principles to
start
did you want to say anything specific
about background independence as a
principle
what does that mean that's basically
background independence says that
in your mathematical description
of the system that you're describing
there's no
fixed mathematical structures which
don't
have a back and forth relation with
other things in other words if this
thing whatever it is influences the
behavior or the evolution of some degree
of freedom
is a reciprocal interaction by which
this thing also changes so there's not
anything which we just use for
reference for coordinates for landmarks
that's not also
dynamic and not also involved
in the analysis of the dynamics
and then um this of course
came from leibniz mach enunciated as
what like what
einstein called mark's principle so
that's an example so
let's just say it um newton liked to say
that one way he could prove that
absolute space was there
is take a bucket half filled with water
and hold it up by some strings and
rotate it and the water would be pushed
up
on the side of the bucket when it was
rotating
and not when it was not and noon said
you see that cruise that when it's
rotating it's rotating relative to
something
which i'm going to call absolute space
and mark said
no you're actually rotating not
in a significant way relative to you
standing there doing the experiment
but you're rotating relative to all the
stars and
stuff in the galaxy and the group of
galaxies
and so forth and the way you could tell
experimentally
is that you should just keep the bucket
fixed
and rotate the whole universe around it
and you would see in that second case
the water go up on the science
the same way and that einstein called
mark's principle
and in general relativity it's true
is it i knew you were going to ask that
yes
but let me finish the sentence
general relativity describes different
kinds of systems with different
what we call boundary conditions kids
missions far away
from the systems we're describing and if
we put on
what are called asymptotic conditions so
we insist that the universe is
just goes to flat space time or some
other
known space time far away then
this principle is not realized because
we're anchoring we're like tying
everything down
it's like tying down the circus tent far
away
but if the universe is conceptualized as
closed
then it is satisfied okay fair enough
so let me see on my list we have
background independence oh wait
i had a sub question sparked by what you
just said um
when you talk about background
independence um and relationalism for
that matter you know this philosophy
that
things are not given things are sort of
uh
constructed with respect to other things
going on in the world
does that go so far as to include
constants of nature you know the fine
structure constant the mass of the
electron things like that
is part of your set of principles that
we should expect
these things that we that that
conventional physics
says there are just data that are given
once and for all in the universe
to be more alive and more dynamical yes
absolutely and that's what cosmological
natural selection was and
um and i'm surprised that
more particle physicists aren't
interested in that idea because that
um let me philosophers are only good
when they're good they're only useful
when they're useful
so we speak i don't think we should just
put up uh
paper mache versions of all the
philosophers and bow down to them
but i was shocked when i had had those
ideas
and then a friend of mine who was a
philosopher
now sent me some pages from purse
charles sanders purse who was a very
influential american philosopher
who in the 1890s said that it's not
enough
to explain nature in terms of laws
the most important thing is to explain
why are those the laws
and he goes on to say that within
science the only
way of explaining why the laws of the
laws is if they're the result of some
evolution
now it is to biology so much for
originality
you can always find things this is why
you shouldn't read things written by
other people because
it makes you sad about your own
contributions so
let me see so what i have here then is
background independence space and time
or relational
causal completeness was another
principle that you mentioned yes
so what does that mean that means there
ain't nothing outside the universe
that means that every explanation in
terms of causes
going back in time has to stay within
this one universe are there people who
don't believe that or are you
is it does it depend on how we define
the word universe
sure okay i mean does cosmological
natural selection fit in with causal
completeness
yes if you define all that as
because there's one causal future okay
and then i have reciprocity which i
guess is related to background
independence so what is wrestling
that was the word for what i was saying
about if a
influences right b and b influences a
and it comes from one of einstein's
papers
on general relativity and this just for
again for the people who are not experts
here
it always bothered me about hidden
variable approaches to quantum mechanics
pilot wave bohmian mechanics ideas
in these ideas you have a wave function
that does the ordinary thing that wave
functions do and everyone else's version
of quantum mechanics
you also have some more variables that
tell you the positions of the particles
and the wave function influences the
particles but the particles do not
influence the wave function so is it
correct to conclude that this bothers
you also
oh yes my god
now that bothered me a lot and i
i mean what i the things that i've come
up with are not as elegant as
boehm de bruyne prof
possibly because i'm trying to really
i tend not to have hidden variables in
that sense
but use non-locality to introduce
non-local interactions between the
degrees of freedom that already
are there so i want to ask how we should
think about these principles
you know here's a list of five
principles they'll evolve over time as
we tweak them like
even the ten commandments aren't exactly
the same in the bible every time they
appear right so we're in good company
there but
do you take these principles as kind of
non-negotiable
like you're so committed to them that
you're only going to consider physics
that satisfies them or is it more like
you're starting with some hypotheses
hypothetical principles and we'll see
whether they take us to the right place
or not
surely more the second okay um
i background independence or
relationalism
and we didn't mention realism but
realism it's not a principle of physics
but it's the principle of doing
science are very important to me and
if if you showed me a film from
200 years in the future and there was a
great successful
physics which violates every one of the
things i deeply hold
here to me i guess i'd
like to know what else is going on in
200 years i
i i'd be surprised but it could sure
i mean one of the things for me
being this kind of scientist is i'm
trying to
get somewhere i'm trying to discover
something
and david finkelstein who was somebody
else who very much worked with
principals
said once to me that the reason why
i think about philosophy and principles
is it gives me a running start so when
i'm sitting here
in 2021 and i'm trying to move forward
if i come with a running start i have a
chance for getting somewhere
right it gives you a little bit of a
guidepost right like you're not just
failing around randomly at least you're
trying to adhere to your principles
that's something
right but they're they're certainly i'm
i mean
you're somebody else who's studying
seriously the
the philosophical literacy literature
and so forth but
i would certainly say i'm not a scholar
you don't trust me for the right
interpretation of any of these people
don't trust me for the history it's all
inspiring
and if if it fails to be inspiring if i
don't get anywhere
then i would certainly be um
looking to one of the things i would
question
would be these principles well and one
of the
potential worries that i had while
reading uh that section of the book was
you you put right there space and time
are relational as one of the principles
and that sort of begs the question
are there things called space and time
in our philosophy like certainly
uh i know that you don't even think that
space is fundamental nor
do i so is it presuming too much to have
the word space and time right there in
one of our foundational principles
what's the alternative well you could
just have a wave function
[Laughter]
oh you may not have well so
what what seems to me or at least
i'm told is the is the
the least popular of the different
positions i've adopted
is the one that says that time is
fundamental
and goes all the way down below space
below laws
right but there is causation so um
and i've developed this with different
collaborators
in the context of a series of several
series of
models the energetic console sets the
causal theory of views etc and i like to
work with models because they're very
concrete
you're not working with it you're not
about deriving abstract things from
abstract
things and i mean sorry maybe even
explain
to the non-scientists out there what you
mean by the word model like that model
has a specific
identity to the mind of a physicist um
so we start by stating some principles
of course loosely and then we
make models of them and i want to
distinguish this
from a theory a model is
something that can be defined by a
small list of rules you can imagine
playing it the way that somebody would
play a game
but a model means that you try to
capture
in the simplest way the implications of
some assumptions
or some phenomena but you don't try to
get all the details
in in in each model
you try to and there's a it's
as i've been a physicist over time i've
learned
to really admire the people who are good
at this which i don't know that i'm
particularly good at but for example per
bar if she knew him he unfortunately
died a long time ago
was a master at making the simplest
model
that illustrated some idea he had about
statistical physics
and so a good model demonstrates or
exhibits some idea clearly
and you can either solve it on a piece
of paper
or put it in a little computer program
and
code it up and it's not any more
complicated
than minecraft so perrbach famously
considered sand dripping onto sand piles
and
and causing little avalanches so that's
a model the simple harmonic oscillator
is a model these like simple idealized
systems that get at some of the
principles we're talking about and you
can hopefully
learn something by studying them in
detail even if no one pretends
they're the whole universe right good
and
i i want to get on to this time being
real and having some real
uh causal power but before we do that
i need to ask some questions about the
principle of sufficient
reason because you say in the book um
in some sense i forget which way it goes
either all of your principles
arise from the principle sufficient
reason or taken together they imply the
principle of sufficient reason so
what is the principle of sufficient
reason and why are you such a big fan
um the principle of sufficient reason is
states that for every fact about the
universe
such that it's possible to ask why is it
this way and not that way
so an example would be if you're talking
about space
why is the universe here and not 10 feet
to the left
if you're talking about time why did the
whole universe start
when it did 13 point whatever billion
years ago
and not 10 minutes later
and this principle of sufficient reason
says
either there is a reasonable
explanation for that that is an
explanation
in law they have the reasonable person
standard so a sort of reasonably
judicious
person would agree that that was an
explanation
or and this is the sort of back edge of
it which is this most important use
or you're asking a question that really
has no meaning
so in the case of those two questions i
named
the issue is not is there a reason why
the universe was not created 10 feet to
the left
but can you construct a cosmological
theory
in which there's meaning to how far los
angeles is from toronto
but there's no meaning to where the
whole universe is
right now right okay but i'm not a fan
of the principle of sufficient reason
and i know i know you are so that's why
i want to sort of dig into this probably
you and i care more about whether or not
this is true than most of the listeners
but we're going to indulge ourselves
i think that it all depends on what you
mean by a reason and you try to invoke a
reasonable person standard but
i'm not quite sure that that qualifies
because we're very far away from what
the reasonable people are familiar with
uh
if i ask a question like why are there
eight planets in the solar system
uh it's mostly an accident i mean i
could
trace it back to the whole initial
conditions for the universe and the laws
of uh
evolution and so forth but that doesn't
strike me as what someone would call a
reason
there's different numbers of planets
around different stars and we happen to
get eight
how does that fit into the principle of
sufficient reason i think
i think you showed how it fits in it's
the result of the history of the
bunch of gas and dust that became our
sources
okay so in that sense it's it's a way of
saying that
the behavior is law like right the
behavior follows some rules and you can
find the current situation given the
earlier situation plus the laws let me
give a harder
a harder case um these are some things
i've been thinking about recently with
some
collaborators over the last few years
were trying to write something about
these kind of things
um supposing you
get interested in biology which i know
you are you have been and
you we get interested in how proteins
get made in the whole story of the
rna and dna and rna and messenger rna
and that whole
complicated thing and we
want to know why
is there a particular protein
that's prevalent in the biosphere
and we imagine
several kinds of explanations there's
the brute force deterministic
explanation of
there were some initial conditions in
the universe the laws are deterministic
and you compute and you compute and it
just happened that way
then there is the functional interpret
explanation that a biologist might want
to give
which says and let me i forgot to say
the most important thing
um there are something like 20 to the
1000 different possible proteins
and those that are found in the
biosphere
are many fewer maybe 10 to the seventh
or ten to the ninth or something
so what distinguishes those
that are found in the biosphere and the
answer is
if you allow functional explanation it
is not very complicated
this molecule makes something which
performs a function
for the beings it is that make it that
make them more viable have a better
fitness
and so forth so there are functional
explanations
and with the interesting challenge let
me start with
there's a certain amount of argument
which
much of which to me is is not to the
point of
well but the we believe in the
determinism
of the laws of physics so that's already
a complete explanation
so the functional bit of the explanation
must be
not relevant or not enlightening but in
fact it is enlightening
and what i would say is that we
we are blessed by having both that is
we can make a functional explanation for
why those proteins exist
and we can also check do they satisfy
the laws of physics
and the laws of chemistry at every stage
in that explanation
but we can't hope with current
technology
to just compute from the wave function
of the universe
whether we whether they would be
prevalent do you see what i'm doing
i do yeah okay i'm going to bite my
tongue because i think that'll get us
down a rabbit hole but we both put our
positions on the table there and i do
want to talk about the reality of time
which i think is very important i mean
you've written a whole book
with a subtitle the reality of time um
but it means different things when you
say that time is real so there's one
sense in which time could be real in
which you're just distinguishing uh
fundamental from emergent right there's
a lot of
approaches to quantum gravity for
example the wheeler dewitt equation
where time is emergent rather than
fundamental but
i in my mind i would still call it real
in either case
but you're a tet sorry of course
yes and you're attaching something a
little bit more
significant to your notion of real that
i would not want to attach i mean i
think that time is real
but it's just a label on different
things much like space
is whereas you're giving time some role
as uh exerting a causal oomph in the
universe and and why don't you give us
the sales pitch for that
point of view well thank you
it's been changing over the course of my
career in
recent years over time over time
um what i want to say
is that what i believe to be the case
is that when we're arguing or we're
discussing
what is fundamental and let me just
reiterate to make sure we mean the same
thing
but the question is not whether it's
real there's lots of emergent
manufactured invented things which are
not
in the laws of physics which are real
which are all around me and
so forth but um the question
we i think it is something that we know
how to do pretty well
to go down in levels of dependence that
is in science
there are there's a certain level where
we use
biological explanation biological
concepts
and then we can explain those
in terms of molecules in the chemistry
of molecules
and we go down a level and certain
concepts at this level
are reduced to concepts which
hold because of the laws of chemistry
and physics
and we can go down a series of levels
like this
um and my belief
and it's interesting that as we go down
levels
concepts get stripped away because
they're
reduced to concepts at the lower level
and um i don't as a side
story we can talk about these with the
different kinds of causation whether
causation can go
up and down both but let me not say that
now let me just talk about
the kind of ontology of it there is
you assert a level or maybe several
levels
where there's no longer a concept that
relates to our experience
of time and i my
hope is that her belief is that that's
not the case
and that as as slow as you go
there will always be time and
in a particular sense and the particular
sense is
that the world at that level
will be will be
a process of events which are
created and which then disappear
and the events have causes which are
prior events that is you can talk about
who
the cause the immune causes of one event
are or some other events and
each of them have prior causes and
the events and that structure of who is
the prior cause to who
is part of what goes all the way down
i'm not done but that's part of the
structure then
um very anachronistically
um i believe that
there is that the correct level of the
correct description
involves a notion of now these are the
events
which are in existence now which are in
the process of being created and about
to be in the process
of creating future events and that
it's not only possible but absolutely
fundamental
to ultimately talk about the world
in terms of what is real now
and that that is the two things
make up the meaning of time when i say
that time is fundamental
the process of the continual creation
of events and the fact that i
believe there's something objective and
universal
in the notion of now it is some time
and in the past some other things
happened they're no longer
happening and some other things may
happen in the future
so a variety of presentism is it safe to
say it's a variety of questions
and in particular you would say i think
that what we call the arrow of time
is something that's built into the
fundamental nature of reality
right and so this is very interesting to
me both you know uh
physically and philosophically so let me
just ask about it in more detail
um so a point of view of someone like me
and i'm not alone
uh is that of course there's an arrow of
time in our everyday experience of the
world
ice cubes melt in glasses of water they
don't un-melt etc etc
but we do more and more understanding of
physics we boil these things down into
something like newton's laws or
schrodinger's equation or maxwell's
equations and suddenly
there is no arrow of time there and
that's okay
because we can still explain the
macroscopic arrow of time
as an emergent collective phenomenon and
somehow you want to put the arrow of
time back
in at an even deeper level than newton's
laws einstein's equations etc so
to someone like me that sounds like a
step backwards
uh we have explained the arrow of time
as this emergent phenomenon and now you
want to
put it back in so i always i always
think i always have questions about this
for myself because
as we make progress in physics and we we
learned that
something that was brute and fundamental
can now be explained
in more fundamental terms um that always
seems like progress and we're reluctant
to let it go
but sometimes we have to let it go right
sometimes we have to take a step
backwards to make
progress so i guess i'm simultaneously
asking you
why you think it's necessary to undo the
progress we made
and how you in general feel about this
move of sometimes admitting that you
have to take a step back to take two
steps forward
good um so let me mention some of the
things that we owe
some of the homework we have to do if we
take the stance
one of them is we have to explain
what was your starting point which is
explain
why there are errors errors in the
history of the universe
that results from our assumptions
in which to a good approximation the
laws look time symmetric
and we have a story about that which
has to do with the formation of limit
cycles and so forth and we've
we have some words and we've studied
this in various models
and we by the way is this work is with
marina cortez
um another thing we have to so we have a
story about that
that i'd be happy to expound if you want
the second thing we have to do
is we have to ask looking at it from the
other way
if you say if you like going backwards
from the present
through the universe is ask
are there extensions of the
physical theories that we use in these
particularly general relativity and
quantum field theory
do they have modifications or extensions
where we see the symmetry
in time reversal failing so that is
there
what i mean a lot of people who are
cosmetologists who work with
to study modifications of general
relativity
it's a big activity are there any
sensible modifications
that lose the time symmetry when you
turn the microphone
and can we therefore see a smooth
transition
described by these theories and maybe
muck around and make some cosmological
predictions
and with andrew little and marina we
have some papers on here
and did you want to say something about
the the general idea
of uh abandoning progress we think we've
made for
a greater purpose i don't know that i
have
sometimes sometimes it's necessary
good okay i don't know that i have a
general um
what you get and many
of the most thoughtful physicists
have been concerned about the apparent
disappearance of the notion of what they
sometimes they call the now
or the present moment you can find
einstein worrying about that
and trying to put back in the
distinction as between
past present and future as a fundamental
distinction
so there's a paper that a collaborator
and i
just posted hopefully it will appear
tonight
um in which we muddle over some very
interesting
quotes of finn and dyson and heisenberg
and schrodinger
in which they say quantum mechanics is
really a description of the future
and the reason why people get confused
about
these issues like the measurement
problem is they don't understand that
the quantum description
is only a description
okay i hate to leave that out there but
i'll link to the paper uh when it comes
out when we publish this episode so
people can look for it themselves
but in other words these very thoughtful
people have
worried about the absence of the notion
of the now
in our physical theory and my
collaborator by the way is clelia
um their day um
and so we're trying to address
this this quiet that these people and
einstein had
over the absence of them well and it
goes i do want to give you a chance to
say a little bit about the specifics of
this uh
theoretical structure you've been
developing uh
i i boiled it down to a statement that
the universe should be thought of as a
series of events not things and each
event has a view
of the universe that's probably too
simplistic but uh maybe you can
elaborate on it
so imagine that
the universe consists of a number of
events
which are created by
some just previous events each event
has a number of progenitors or parent
events
and each event gives rise to a number of
we can just call them children
events and that this is the basic
dynamics of the universe this is how the
universe
really runs under everything um
is it fundamentally discrete then yes
okay it's fundamentally discreet um
it's i'm not yet using the language of
quantum theory
because one of our results
is that in several of these models we
can show the emergence
of quantum theory so at the moment
what is real is these events
the causal processes that continually
create them
and we insist on keeping in the
description
energy and momentum whereas a lot of
people at that level
see those as things that go out the door
come back as emerging
um there is a notion of the view
of such an event the view is basically
justifying now as an event and look
around you
and what you see what's coming at you is
a whole lot of photons and hopefully not
too many other stuff
which has ranges of energies
which impinge on you and
this is i'm using this as a kind of
metaphor but
see yourself right now as an event and
your view is all these things that are
coming to you
that inform you of the world in your
neighborhood
or equivalently in your council past and
what we do so this world has no space
so there's no forces that can fall off
at one over distance squared or
any other factor there's no functions of
space
there's no derivatives so we can't write
any field equations
so how are we going to do dynamics and
one of the ideas
is that these views are
the stuff that dynamics acts upon
in particular the fundamental laws
exist that can give a measure to how
different
the views of two events are and the
fundamental dynamics
is expressed as a certain function
of differences between the between views
of different events averaged over the
universe
as it exists now and we have an
operational meaning of now
basically an event is part of now
if it has been created
but it hasn't yet made all the children
that it's going to make
and um that's a anyway that's the
that gives us a notion of a present and
that's the that's the fundamentals
so it does seem i mean compared to my
own more evoredian views it does seem
even if you can in some limit recover
quantum mechanics it seems pretty
classical
to me in that there is sort of a set of
events and that's it that's the set
it's not like the sum over every
possible set of events
and uh but maybe that is just in
concord with your feeling that there is
only one universe and if we really went
completely
uh to superimpose all the different
universes that would not be what you're
looking for
well there's a view that cleo verde and
i are trying to
make work in this new paper which
brings in some parts of quantum theory
um what we say
is that the fundamental distinction is
not the difference between the past
present and future the fundamental
distinction is between
some properties that are incompletely
known
or indefinite and some quantities that
are definite
and that what an event is is a moment of
transition
of some indefinite quantity becoming
definite
and we then try to make a very
um a simple picture of the world in
which everything stems from that
and you do have a principle in there or
at least uh i don't know a law or
whatever you want to call it
that you maximize the diversity of these
views
which sounds like a uh social justice
statement from the university but you
have definite uh
physical definitions for diversity and
view here they're a little bit different
yes and that's of course getting a
little bit of satire
in which it's given the present
crazy world we thought was useful
but let me give that definition because
it's not very
difficult and this actually was invented
with julian barber
way back in the 80s julian was i don't
know if everybody
knows who julian is a historian
of physics and a philosopher of physics
and a physicist as well
and he was the mentor
for myself and for other people of my
generation
to to teach us these ideas about
relationalism
i mean the first time i met him he asked
me if i had new lives
and i said live with food yeah and
um so this is something that julian and
i
just invented and the
idea is basically that we take all pairs
of views in the universe
compare them give a numerical
measure of how different they are and
some that square that and sum that over
all parents and that's what we call the
variety
of a system and this is maximized either
by assumption or
do you show that it's true no we put it
um i'll use the technical term and then
i explain it
we put it in the action particularly
um it's it's absolute value
is the potential energy okay
and it's rate of change between
events and events just causally prior to
them
is the kinetic energy and so the idea is
that we have a bunch of events
and they all have their views and we can
calculate the variety the diversity
amongst the different views but in a
very down-to-earth physical sense we
maximize that
and the hope is our universe comes out i
mean can i ask how much of our universe
has come out so far do we recover
einstein's equation for general
relativity no
here's what we recover we recover
space and actually space time
so what becomes emergent
so originally in the theory there's
momentum but there's no positions
but what emerges is a minkowski in space
time
with an embedding that takes these
events to points of view
space one um two
um motion of particles
of relativistic particles in that
mechanism um
three and these are as there's a
quantity which i'll just call one over n
and i can come back and i can tell you
more about what it is
for one over n goes to zero or n goes to
infinity
we get the classical trajectory for
that leaving order in the correction so
that's one over square root of n
um and taking a certain non-relativistic
limit
and making certain assumptions about the
initial conditions
um we derive a version of quantum
mechanics as we derive
the schrodinger equation acting on a
complex wave function
with corrections that are would be look
like
nonlinear functions of the wave function
okay we can conclude um
let me stop there that's there are other
things that are in progress
but that's what's been published but
okay but then the hope is to keep going
and show that you do get curved space
time and einstein's equation and maybe
even
the standard model of particle physics
yes it would be great
but with the caveat that you you want to
imagine that the laws of physics
themselves
change over time or can change over time
yes
so does that have an experimental
consequence do we expect to see slight
variations in the fine structure
constant or something like that
that's a very very very interesting
question um
the cosmological natural selection which
just to go way back as we said makes two
predictions
um the idea that the constants of nature
change in cosmology in modern cosmology
goes back to duran
as as i'm sure you know and
he looked for changes in means constant
and they've been looked for repeatedly
and not confirmed
i i don't remember what the level is now
but it's
it's several r's magnitude past g dot
over g
right in hubble units um i
i don't know there there are there's so
many things about this which
let me put this thing there are a few
things about this stuff which i feel
i have under control and there's a lot
of things which i don't know the answer
okay well that's fair i mean that's how
science goes so we can't can't blame you
for that i'm just asking because i was
wondering how things were going
um good so to finish up i have two
questions
one is uh you mentioned as we were
chatting
before we actually came on that i made
an
offhand remark that caused you to do a
u-turn
and you didn't say what the remark was
or what the u-turn was so maybe let's
hear that later
yes and this i very much thank you for
although i don't think you like cap
so um something that we haven't touched
on
yet is the whole issue of the mind the
brain
qualia and all that which most of my
career
i felt like was too hard to mess with
so i stayed away from that consciousness
yeah yeah
all that but i have published
one paper written and published one
paper
and it's a result of a remarkably so
um ever since college i was
a naive um
pan psychist um or
this the sophisticated the fancy word
for it is a reselling
monist and that is i believe
that qualia and conscious experiences
are real and there are other aspects
of the matter which makes up our brain
and therefore you you get to have
the determinism of the laws of physics
making explaining everything that
happens in the brain
so you know you're not a duelist
functionally or causally but you get to
be a duelist
as to the kinds of properties that
things have and there are
external relational properties by which
things move around that
physics describes and there are
according to this view
other inner or intrinsic qualities
which are like color the experience of
colors and sound
and which we know what they're like for
our brain because we inhabit our brain
but why not just say that the whole
world has that dual aspect so i think
now that's a really dumb idea
i mean i respect the people who had it
but um what we said
it's funny how to sound so this was a
momentary conversation
going into a talk and you said
but that doesn't make any sense because
why would nature
whatever qualia and consciousness are
if they have no causal influence in the
world because
the causes are already explained by
physics um
why should nature be part of them what
what are they doing in the world
and several years later i found myself
thinking about that
and i the conclusion i came to
and this i'm very changeable on because
this is
very current stuff but i said jesus must
be right
therefore consciousness must actually
have
causal power in the world which is
the which is not the conclusion you drew
from it but it is a natural conclusion
to draw and therefore
and i basically so i made then
a hypothesis about correlation
or representative which is with the
people in this consciousness business
are saying they're looking for neural
correlates
of quality or consciousness so given the
situation i just described to you with
views
there's another aspect of the theory of
views
which is that not every
view has um fixed
consequences and you you're gonna have
to give me a little time to justify this
but
most views have fixed consequences
which are the same as would have
happened to similar views in the past
but in order to believe that the laws
can change
i have to believe that
some very small minority of youths
are not don't have precedent or
the laws of nature don't know what to do
with them and they have to somehow
discover
novel behavior and now a response to
their situation
and so the hypothesis is that it's those
that correspond to events which have to
do with quality of consciousness
and so i wrote a paper about that i was
very excited about that
i wrote a paper about it and i'm glad
that paper is out there
and i did not i'm basically
i'm very confused i don't know how you
feel i
i feel that we have as scientists
our descendants as the scientists of two
or three or 500 years in the future
i'm going to have to grapple with this i
feel like i grappled with it and i
got an idea and put it out there
but i don't wake up in the mornings
feeling excited about how i'm going to
go to work on that idea
i i feel like it's it's beyond i
it's beyond where science can be
we can imagine things but we we don't
know how to reason about them
well philip gough was a previous guest
on the podcast uh
big advocate for pan psychism am i
correct in thinking that you
like myself were invited to contribute
to uh
this journal of consciousness study
special issue about his work
yes so it made me think of it because i
just handed in my paper in which i
precisely say
that look you can either modify
the laws of physics to allow
consciousness to poke things around and
have a causal influence
or you don't and if you don't you can
say well there's still something
mental that is an aspect of the world
that just has no influence on how things
behave
or consciousness is just an emergent
property from the
true physical behavior of things and my
attitude was
if you want to modify the laws of
physics if you want to have real mental
aspects that have a causal influence
then be my guest like that's hard
there's a large barrier to entry because
we know a lot about the laws of physics
but at least it's respectable
but this idea that mental aspects are
there
and somehow utterly important yet have
zero causal influence that's what i said
i don't even quite consider to be
respectable that's my own personal view
i'm a physicalist myself
i think it can emerge but uh the idea
that you're not
going to have any effect on the standard
model of particle physics and yet
there's this crucial aspect of the
universe i'm not quite sure how that's
supposed to work
yeah so i so thank you
i got to that place and um
yeah it's let me let me say something
generally because we both
had the experience of being physicists
and getting interested in and opening up
to
discourse with philosophers and
sometimes it's very it's been it's
certainly been very useful to me
very helpful um i mean we didn't mention
it all but you started to mention my
books on time
and one of them was with roberto
mandibera hunger
who has been a very very important
influencer
and is i think really an important
philosopher that
people should should pay more attention
to um
and then there's kind of all the people
we know
um the people in oxford and new york
where they're all both places with their
really excellent philosophers of physics
and i find it very
very both inspiring and
um humbling to interact with them
i mean they are likely to know what's
wrong what
what all the arguments are against any
of you you came to them
it's frustrating yes but it is very
helpful to to talk to them for exactly
that reason
so which leads me very nicely into the
very last question i have
you've been very uh indulgent with me
with your time here so
one of the ways one of the ways in which
i think that you and i are a little bit
different but is
i'm glad that there is diversity of
views in the in the usual sense not
in the physics sense is that when we
have a puzzle in physics when there's
something we don't fully understand
whether it's consciousness or
the arrow of time or the foundations of
quantum mechanics
there's various ways one can go in
hypothesizing how to
do better and my first impulse
is always i think what wheeler called
radical conservatism right like keep the
basic ingredients as solidly as you can
the schrodinger equation the physical
nature of
matter uh boltzmann's statistical
mechanics etc
and try to see how from those simple
ingredients
we can reach this a better understanding
of the thing that we're
trying to get to whereas i get the
impression that
uh you and people uh who uh are on the
similar path
are just much more willing to say nope
let's just throw out everything let's
throw out the schrodinger equation and
let's just
change the fundamental nature of matter
because these are big problems and we're
not going to solve them without big
solutions
so do you have any uh any any words of
wisdom
short or long about the the differences
between these two
philosophies do you think that one is
sort of generally better or do you think
that it's just
good that different people are trying
different things i think they're both
necessary and um
one thing that would be very interesting
at some point is
is to have a conversation with you and
carlo
if i may and maybe a few other people i
put carlo
more and more in that same kind of work
although he's announced he didn't stand
up he didn't start out there
and but one one of the interesting
things about
this profession is we get to watch each
other evolve
for old lifetimes um
there were a couple of things that were
really formative to me
i i would first i did part of an
undergraduate degree
in philosophy but as i said
you know i wrote a paper in philosophy
of mind which took this
view that we both criticized and i was
to the extent i thought about
consciousness at all i was satisfied
with that
um it was the problem
of the landscape of string theory or any
other kind of
theory and how are we going to explain
where
the choice of laws come from had a very
destabilizing effect on me
it got me thinking about things that
most of my friends and colleagues were
not thinking about
um something that was also destabilizing
and it's hard to i in my life it seems
like
people play a big role and friends and
people who are not friends who i talked
with i was illustrated about a story
take a big role
i mean the first person who argued with
me
when i was a regular i mean after all we
found the wheel of the wood equation so
how could i not
be in love with that yeah but then we
found out what was hard it happens in
that approach
you can almost by inspection find
solutions of the wheel of jewelry but
but quantum mechanics
is more than just the wave functions
it's especially a theory with a lot of
division variants
it's the observables and the inner
product
and what we never did in conventional
hamiltonian lupine gravity was find
quantum mechanical observables that were
honest dirac quantum mechanical
observables
and that was nor did we ever construct
the physical in the product
and so that program was very frustrating
to me
and that had a big influence and then i
was about to say potini marco poulo
was the first person who just came and
sat me down and said
look you're wasting your time that will
never work
um you have to think about time maybe
being fundamental
in space not she was the first person
who articulated that idea in our
community
and she articulated it very to me very
powerfully now of course
i have seen somebody who was very
important to me
generally and i have enormous respect
for her
but that intervention played a role
and a few years after that i started
working with roberto
randy better unger and he basically took
me the task
and said what kind of he wouldn't quite
say like that but what kind of fool are
you
i mean here you are talking about the
laws changing in the landscape
and here you're working on getting time
to emerge from the wheel of joint
equation
like doesn't that bother you and
so so it's been very important
who who i talk to and listen to
and i feel like over the last 10 years
or so and it took that long
so there were always these elements but
i was working on human variable series
every few years and so forth
but all of this really coalesced into
this research
program over the last 10 years yeah
well whether or not the laws of physics
change with time i'm glad that our
views of the laws of physics are
changing over time because we don't know
them yet and we have to be a little bit
flexible about it so elise mullen thanks
very much for being on the mindscape
podcast
oh thank you very much
[Music]
you